Welcome to Rocky Springs:...
Future home to the greenest community ever built.
So, you're gonna take out the whole forest?
Yeah!
But we're replacing it with a shopping mall with a forest theme.
This is an opportunity to do something good for our family and for the environment.
How is ripping out the forest good for the environment?
The only thing standing in the way are the locals.
You can't run.
You can't hide.
The animals are out to get me.
This is insane.
Shut up!
You can't escape the furry.
Help me!
You're building on a nature preserve,...
...and nature's ticked off.
Brendan Fraser.
You have a family.
All this time you were protecting them.
Come on, little fella.
Furry Vengeance.
Honey, are you in there?
Don't worry, we will have you down in no time.
You might wanna cover your eyes.